hey guys all right i have another tip
and this one is
on an antiviral remedy there is a
natural compound that you can
destroy the mechanism and it dissolves
the outer envelope around the virus
because it's a fat layer
and so this thing goes in there and
dissolves it and the remedy is called
monolorin and what is monolauren it's a
natural compound in coconut oil it's
also in breast milk but you're probably
going to get it in coconut oil
monolaurin is a super concentrated
lauric acid
okay so it's a fat a healthy fat it's
really good for the immune system but it
dismantles viruses
and so if you have a chronic fatigue
syndrome or some type of
flu virus or some type of herpes or
whatever
but it's also good for
resistant type viruses resistant type
bacteria so if you want to bulletproof
your immune system that's one thing you
might want to
check out and see if it can help you all
right
thanks for watching